i'm going to tell you some things about
learning data science that aren't
necessarily going to make me the most
popular
but if you're a brand new data scientist
or you're just trying to break into the
field for the first time these are
probably things you need to hear i'm
richard and this is richard on data
so the internet is littered with videos
and medium articles about learning data
science fast maybe you can learn data
science in six months maybe even three
months or just straight up fast and
wouldn't that be great i mean i get why
people sell this idea for multiple
reasons data science is both a very
nebulous concept but also a very
lucrative career path
so if you're able to boil down exactly
what it is
learn the key concepts and then use that
as a launching point to get a really
good career going that would obviously
be pretty fantastic but as the saying
goes if it sounds too good to be true it
probably is
the world can be a very complex and
messy place
that goes for data science and the
process of learning it too so i'm going
to try to give you the most realistic
possible picture of what the journey of
actually learning data science will look
like as well as the stumbling blocks
you're likely to run into and the
uncomfortable truth about learning data
science is that it's not something that
you can just do in three months or six
months or really even in a year
in fact it's not even really a singular
act it's more of a mentality or a
process
but we'll talk more about that now just
as a disclaimer before we get started i
am not a licensed career counselor i'm
just a data scientist who makes videos
and who has opinions
so just bear that in mind take this
video as just some helpful food for
thought as well as for entertainment
purposes
and then before we get started please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and please take half a second to
smash the like button because that
really does help my content reach a
larger audience
also if you guys would be willing to
support my channel i'll have links in
the description to my patreon account
and my crypto wallet addresses your
support is highly appreciated so before
we talk about the challenges with
learning data science we have to address
the fact that everybody's data science
experience is different if you work at a
major tech company
your experience with data science is
likely to be vastly different than
somebody who works in let's say
healthcare or pharma and then let's
suppose you're in the united states even
things like the region and the local job
market that you're in are likely to
strongly influence your data science
experience like for example are you in
the midwest are you in silicon valley
are you in new york city
those are all going to lend to different
sorts of experiences at your company you
might have more process or less process
you might be really heavy into
statistics or you might not really see
how statistics gets applied from day to
day at all
maybe your company is really heavy into
ai maybe it's really heavy into
interactive visualizations it all really
depends this truly is one of the biggest
challenges with prescribing learning
pathways for data science
because there's not even really a
unanimous agreed-upon definition of data
science and because experiences in it
vary so widely
there really is no
one-size-fits-all sort of approach to
learning it and keep in mind i've done
my own video on a proposed study pathway
for data science and the link to that
will be in the description but even to
my own video there are a number of
caveats to it
for example you really have to think
about the type of data scientist that
you want to be
so you do have to get some fundamentals
down but after that there is a little
bit of flexibility there are some
universal things that i think a very
high percentage of data science jobs are
going to expect you to know specifically
i think those things are statistics sql
and at least one of r and python after
that point you can learn more
programming languages you can learn
linear algebra you can learn user
experience machine learning cloud
computing
whatever the case may be you definitely
have some options depending on the type
of data scientist that you want to be
and where you perceive your own
interests or weaknesses to be another
layer to this is maybe you want to be
somebody who has a pretty broad
knowledge of several topics that is more
of a generalist
or you're somebody with a deeper
knowledge of fewer things that is a
specialist i've also talked about this
in a separate video but in almost all
circumstances no matter what it is that
you do
you're going to end up being a data
scientist who can't get every possible
job out there
but who's going to be massively valuable
and employable to the right company now
let's take a step back here for a second
if you're trying to learn data science
that means you're probably either in
school or you're working some other kind
of job and you're just learning things
either at that job or kind of on the
side on your own time probably later
down the road you'll break into an entry
level or associate level data science
job or perhaps you'll make some kind of
lateral transition and unfortunately
when you're getting your first data
science job
usually the options aren't exactly
endless it's a little bit harder than it
would be with a little bit more
experience
but that's okay because all you need is
to find that one company
almost everybody eventually can find
that one company where you can finally
kick things off but even then you are
probably going to have to go through
some kind of technical screening you
might get asked about some concept in
statistics or what some statement in sql
means or
how you would solve some problem using r
or python or maybe something else
completely different altogether and now
this is the point where i'd really like
you to think and be as brutally honest
with yourself as you possibly can with
these types of technical screenings and
they are pretty common
which type of person do you think is
going to have the higher chance of
success with them
somebody who's covered a pretty broad
number of topics over the span of like
three to six months
or somebody who's practiced and applied
these things for a much longer period of
time now far be it for me to give
credence to those companies that demand
a ridiculous and artificial number of
years of experience in various
programming languages because many of
those people are pretty silly in their
own right but you'd also probably never
expect somebody to become fluent in a
foreign language in let's say three to
six months either
granted programming languages are easier
than that but it's not that far off so
why am i making this video anyway
is it to attack or to make fun of people
who are promising results in learning
data science in a short period of time
no it's not that at all i'm sure that in
many programs or videos where people lay
out those kinds of pathways there's a
lot of value there and i am all about
efficiency you should strive to do more
with less in ways that make sense of
course but it's to emphasize the point
that the process of learning is not some
concrete thing that starts at some point
and then ends at a later point
it's something that never really truly
ends it doesn't even end when you break
into data science and get your first job
why because no job is permanent you
might get bored of your company you
might want to move to a different
industry because you want to try
something different
you might get laid off or maybe you want
to move away for personal reasons things
happen
but if you end up lacking skills that
are valuable in the broader data science
marketplace
you could end up needlessly excluding
yourself from amazing opportunities out
there
granted once you're working a job you
shouldn't be in overdrive like killing
yourselves on nights and weekends trying
to learn things on the side you've got a
job you can pump the brakes a little bit
you should be methodical and try to
focus on one or maybe two things at a
time
don't try to take too much on or you
could end up burning yourself out or not
really learning things efficiently in
the first place
but every year or every few months or so
you should be able to take a written
inventory of the new skills that you've
learned the additional months or years
of experience you have at different
things whether that's r or python or
anything else as well as just to take
stock in the interesting projects and
tasks that you've worked on
if you find yourself unable to do that
that's a giant red flag and problem
so just to bring everything here full
circle i think that everybody watching
this video intrinsically understands
that data science is an incredibly
rewarding and lucrative career path but
you do have to know what kind of data
scientist that you are or at least the
kind of data scientist you want to be
based on your own interests and
strengths and weaknesses and to be
honest with yourself
it's helpful to have your eye on the
market just to see the kind of
opportunities that are out there and to
identify the ones that appeal most to
you
as well as to get some idea of the types
of skills and experience level that's
required it's frankly never been easier
to do that now that we're in this sort
of era of remote work
and even if some of these opportunities
are out of reach right now maybe they
won't be in a year or a few years
you will maximize your chance of landing
those opportunities and by extension of
that having the most fulfilling work
possible that pays you the most by
continuously learning the more you've
learned and the more you've actually
gone to apply the things you've learned
the more opportunities there will be
available to you
and again by extension that means the
more profitable you're likely to be and
that's why learning does not stop after
three or six months or even after you've
gotten the first job that you want
it's almost a cliche but it's true that
if you're not growing you're dying so
now that's all well and good but how do
you actually learn data science well you
do that by subscribing to my channel
obviously
no but in all seriousness ideally you
take the right courses in school
or if you're working a job hopefully
that gives you some opportunities to
learn various things that are useful for
data science
obviously that's not always an option
for everybody so if that's not for you
then you want to gain some exposure to
the fundamental topics coursera courses
are a fantastic way of doing that or
alternatively there are some amazing
books out there for data science i'll
have links to some great ones in the
description of this video and you also
want to practice the things you've
learned again if you have a job in which
you're able to do this that's ideal but
if not kaggle challenges are way better
than nothing and they provide you a
great opportunity to learn the things
that you didn't realize you didn't know
it really is a marathon not a sprint
but if you commit to just taking that
first step
getting started and then making learning
a habit
you are going to be successful i can
pretty much guarantee that so thanks for
watching this video if you enjoyed it
smash the like button
then let me know in the comments down
below what you thought did you agree
with me did you disagree with me let me
know
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then
richard on data